- I'm an American in
every sense of the word,
I know Cardi B.
- Yeah.
(laughs)
(upbeat music)
In what country is this possible?
You come from Africa and
you're in Hollywood now.
All my life I've kinda like,
hidden my immigration status,
and it wasn't until they
decided to cancel it that
I was like, look, I
can't be scared anymore.
I can't hide in the shadows anymore.
I'm in Black Panther, I'm in
The Good Place and I feel like,
to whom much is given, much
is expected or required.
- Yeah.
- So, I decided to
use my voice and to amplify the message
and to actually put a face to the, to this
real political issue.
- Yeah.
- That a lot of people don't
understand or know about.
I'm a dreamer, meaning
I'm a DACA recipient.
This is Deferred Action
for Childhood Arrivals that
Obama signed as an
executive order in 2012, and
Trump Administration decided
to cancel it back in September.
- [Chanting Protesters] The
whole world is watching!
The whole world is watching!
- There's not a day that
undocumented people go without
a thought of possibly being
torn away from everything that
they love, from their
family, from the life that
they've built here because of
sometimes, just a minor technicality.
You don't renew your visa and all of a
sudden, you're rendered illegal.
You can't adjust your
status to anything else.
Like, I came here when I was
10 years old with my parents,
seeking political asylum,
fleeing war, and now,
I'm on DACA and I've been in this country
25 years and my whole life, I just thought
I could achieve a lot of success.
I could just be great
at everything that I do.
Try to be a model citizen,
give back to the community and
then eventually, the thing
would work, there just
seems like there's no door,
there's no way to actually
adjust the status, I've tried everything.
People are like, well, you didn't do this.
No, I've seen as many lawyers as possible.
I'm doing everything that you
can humanly do just so that
I can have the peace
of mind that, you know,
I'm gonna be okay and my
family won't be torn apart.
We're not murderers or killers, we're not
trying to take away from
America, we love America.
We just want an opportunity
to have a permanent solution.
We want Congress to
finally pass a Dream Act.
America's at a crossroad,
and Americans have a
decision to make as far as like,
what country does America wanna be?
Americans have been able
to break walls of race,
of gender inequality, of
disability, of just so many
amazing things which
makes this country great.
That's, that's the America that I love and
I believe and I want to remain in.
(mellow music)